E aí
[Música]
E era uma vez uma menina que amava
dançar
uma passada no grupo tá lado do
resultados Fernandes Vera Cruz vai lado
da Ilha da Madeira
o crescimento em desfalques diz o Teatro
Municipal Baltazar dias ao Cassino entre
outros e quando dançada sentia Tu muda a
alegria do mundo e tudo em Jesus precisa
e deste modo mandava energia para poder
ultrapassar Os desafios da vida
e a pizza menina também amava ajudar o
próximo para o sofá seu médico quando
essa nossa saudade só vai ficar sem
cansada quando vai personagem é doença
que estava lágrimas aos doentes em um
sorriso maravilhoso quando eles
finalmente voltaram a terceiros e
o sakis de menina
o almoço na Dutra e aos seus 18 anos
tinha que escolher a que iria fazer toda
a sua vida esta menina então escolheu
medicina vou trocar a melhor maneira de
ajudar o próximo
eu entro em cena
é só caseira
Há muitos nãos
a ser entrar no quarto lá na faculdade
seu pai que eu doentes e sou de ferro
E aí
E é só eu tirar um aumento negro e mais
poderoso
a festa menina
é adulta
E aí
bom então adoro tão grande que esta
rapariga
pen drives e Nextel oficial e também da
igreja
E aí
É Essa Menina leve
bom então logo eu fui submetida a exames
e nesses anos desse doce que eu tenho
uma doença que a a doença em muito rara
métrica de graça que a neurofibromatose
o anel se lá na tá os dois é uma doença
Rara Só Feita Uma um 44 mil pessoas em
todo o mundo é
O que é uma doença genética porque taça
de pais para filhos felizmente e fui o
primeiro caso na minha família e não
aceitou a minha mãe nem Às vezes isso
que que entrar tá esta doença da horas
em todo o corpo na minha mente a nível
cerebral no nervo auditivo outros quilos
tive local criar ao afetar o nezo
plástica vai fazer então casa teto ao
chão e perda de Equilibrio
a festa dura Norte notar Esse realmente
achatada
o saco no meu pai
eu tinha pedido para te contei que seria
olhar da minha vida e que terminaria um
gatinho melhor do que eu encontrar aqui
e assim Tão tentando mas isso não é
E a neném sempre foi um grande tório
leve favor põe nisso febre emocional
bom Então olha taxa o seu unimos a
tentar continuar a nossa se deitar olhar
é realmente quando cheguei a a parte em
que disse que inicializar ensino sabe ar
quem eu tinha passado muito e nessa
altura já estava sempre cheio de Saddam
Que horas tem sente saudade não está
sempre sincera de ser até a minha mãe
disse-me filha
Tu vai hoje tá melhor que tu podes
correr bem assim se não correr vai além
de Chávez deixa o teu olhar e deve ser o
no WhatsApp área
e esse foi some e graças a Deus correu
muito bem e então tornei na primeira
médica 100% surda em Portugal
bom então a conseguir esse feito pensei
que significa criar algo que realmente
precisa disso interessa Olha a escola
dos seus fui fazer pessoas não a
consulta de ensinar porque quem tinha
que ir no médico mas entra na forma e
então agora não levar os médicos não
sabem a língua gestual não entendem nem
um
bom então não né O que que eu pensar
criar uma consulta e se esquentar ao
surda e assim feio
Olá tudo essa ideia tornou-se realidade
então criei é consulta Não é preciso
pressionar do surf O que é que está a
consulta real entrar sem trás autonomia
ao ácido te que ela não precisa levar
ninguém para para explicar o que é que
ele tem importante em suas vidas chegar
eu sozinha além disso nesse consulta
torcendo saída auxiliar consigo abordar
ainda a parte das áreas o que é Tom tens
a saúde e sentir as saúde do adulto
saúde do idoso segundo na perna acesso
ao planeamento familiar
bom então assim passei a de agir um
é também nesta consulta Pinto criar um
mundo onde haja realmente uma melhor
minha mãe tinta seguinte a comunidade
surda EA comunidade em geral ou seja se
mundo é importante incentivar melhor
para isso tenho tentado funk sucedidos
não desistam dos seus sonhos a farra que
todos os elementos se interessa segundo
ano e que querem conseguir trânsito que
fazem os seus direitos e que fazem os
seus deveres e destinado tenho
conseguido a poucos todos tenham maior e
melhor qualidade de vida
eu amanheci entre os surdos que
dissessem que primas é que gostariam de
explicar Se eu te pegasse não entendam
tampar digo isso porque tenho sangue
sessões de educação para a saúde e que
ele tem sempre ficar uma forma simplista
a existe mas terceirizar também tem Rita
e tens feito com tração integral dos
surdos em geral
Olá tudo acordar
é só que vida
eu continuo dar aos seus pontapés de
Velozes
é um andas na lei 14 você tem amadores
tão cansada
é especialmente durante a
é tão doente que os pega aqui na mente
nem Portugal disseram que apenas seriam
dar cuidados paliativos
é mas até se eu alugar
E aí vai descobrir assim cinética assim
sai e percebemos que a em Manchester
Reino Unido existe um centro
especializado em neurocirurgia situações
Ines centro estão em di14 começaram a
fazer uma cirurgia Pioneira e essencial
no cirurgia colocação de um implante
auditivo de tronco esse degrau sim para
este implante nos se dispõem a minha
patologia é essencial porque os
implantes cocleares são colocados os
implantes de normais são colocadas num
frase ler só que nesta tecnologia era a
cidade aquela ser o que é que contém
O livro é Hannover Porque mesmo que está
o senhor
bom então este infantis e fabuloso
porque não é porque já não existe mas
sim na parte a defesa do cérebro nos
núcleos cocleares
bom então este é
I had to your friends and and plan esta
parte que é colocada segurar no fazer
auricular e essa parte é esse Coloca
a pelada ao Infante auditivo hora essa
blusa de flores torna os Esquilos artes
em estilo Celebrar Eternit confirmou sei
realmente
o grande presente da vida porque a
adereços oficial audição normal mancha é
algo Então o que é que aconteceu fui
também outras vezes a terminar
portuguesa a ter acesso e cinco antes e
assim cria em que ninho muito nele para
outros com esta tecnologia ainda não
sabe Se surgir em Portugal mas estamos a
fazer tudo isso desligar
bom então vocês antes de continuar esses
consultas e agradeço a Deus que essas
consultas tem sido não na nara de ir
encontrado muitas vezes ajudar as
pessoas com essa tecnologia
Tô confusa
a menina que na dançar
o cara lá ainda na dançar dançar o
próximo e quase que o seu sonho ser
médica esse look e escrever então
irritado mas não sei professor em still
com outros problemas de saúdes a Síria a
melhor a doença Negra a cidade atrás
dois mas no entanto tem voz alta para
nosso médica e diz que nós também teve a
oportunidade motor em são as suas ideias
contra fazer a consulta seca facilidade
desse jeito consultas uma gente passasse
a ser tão as coisas que não entendem
entre outras coisas
É sim é tudo mostrar a média Nunca nem
que seja negro tá fazer milagres então a
personagem realidade muita coisa que nós
queremos tem esse nunca desistir sim tem
excelentes e tentar tomar um cantinho do
mundo o melhor que a gente encontrou
os exames grow esteiras e grooves o pai
Kennedy E são essas dificuldades que nós
temos em oportunidades
e parabéns sair o concretizar todos os
nossos sonhos não vamos ter sempre tomar
um cantinho na nossa vida melhor do que
encontramos a